MAX SALTONSTALL: Have you
ever wanted to be a hacker?
Have you ever
thought about how you
would gain access to a system
you weren't supposed to?
Well, in this
video, you're going
to see how you can make
Add a Cat to That more
secure by donning
your own attacker hat
and trying to break it.
When it comes to security,
you don't just flip a switch
and suddenly your app is secure.
Instead of thinking
of it as yes or no,
it's better to think
of it as a spectrum.
Even with an app as simple
as Add a Cat to That,
we've got a lot of work
to keep our application
from becoming one of those
security horror stories
you read about.
There's a few ways we
can make some progress.
The first step is putting
on our attacker hat
and doing an exercise
called threat modeling.
In threat modeling, you
take advantage of the fact
that you are the best person
to attack your software.
You have the most
in-depth knowledge of it.
Then you use those
possible attack methods
to make your
application more secure.
Remember, an attacker
is probably not
going to just randomly
poke at your software.
They have a goal in mind.
This might be your user data,
financial information you have,
or the goal could be something
outside your organization.
Perhaps, they want
to take advantage
of an open source library you
maintain that other people use.
Whatever the goal, they won't
be able to get straight at it,
because if it's
important to you,
it's probably pretty
well protected.
So an attacker is going to
look for intermediate resources
as stepping stones.
They're going to
investigate your environment
and try to find
different pieces they
can take advantage
of to make it further
into your infrastructure.
These intermediate
resources could
be servers running in a cluster,
libraries you depend on,
or even your
developers themselves.
As your attackers
investigate, they're
going to try to learn about
any defensive measures you have
in place, password policies,
auditing practices, firewall
rules, and the like.
They're probably going to start
the process of enumerating
all these things
from information
they can find online.
And they might find a way to
use all that to wiggle around
your defensive measures to get
access to information, or plant
malware, or other
nefarious things.
This series of steps leading
to a successful attack
is called the kill chain.
And it's our job to stop it.
Our first impulse after
figuring out a kill chain
is I want to take one of
our defensive measures
and just beef it up.
Add more firewall rules.
Segment the network.
Instead, focus on
reducing the attack
surface of the pieces you use.
That means removing
unnecessary components
and simplifying services and
APIs to reduce an attacker's
possible entry points.
And rather than having one
strong measure in place,
it's more effective to
employ defense in depth.
Use a greater number
of defensive measures
that overlap.
That way if one thing
fails for whatever reason,
you have another backup
behind it to protect you.
The big idea?
Build up your defenses in
layers so that the attacker has
to cry as they peel the onion.
Now that you've seen
the defensive strategy,
be sure to subscribe
below to see
how you can use it to
protect your supply chain,
automatically discover
vulnerabilities,
and minimize phishing.
Thanks for watching
and for letting
me rock this excellent hat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]